vamos a jugar a ser detectives de
números fíjate muy bien tendremos que
encontrar los números que nos hacen
falta para completar las siguientes
sucesiones hey que la palabra no te
instante una asociación es solo un grupo
de números que llevan un orden
empezaremos con una muy fácil tenemos 9
12 15 18 y luego una rayita
eso significa que necesitamos encontrar
el número que va después del 18 como lo
haremos primero tenemos que darnos
cuenta de cómo van cambiando los números
mira tenemos 9 y luego un 12 pero como
llegamos del 9 al 12 si contamos de uno
en uno después del 9 seguiría en el 10 y
el 11 pero como están escondidos por eso
sólo aparece el 12 quiere decir que hay
2 números que no vemos por lo tanto el
tercer número es el que pertenece a la
sucesión en este caso el 2
del 12 al 15 pasa igual tenemos dos
números escondidos porque después del 12
sigue en el 13 y el 14 y el número que
aparece es el 15 así que otra vez el
tercer número es el que tenemos en la
sucesión del 15 al 18 lo mismo 16 y 17
escondidos y el 18 es el que ya tenemos
entonces después del 18 que número
seguiría
escondemos dos números en este caso 19 y
20 y escribimos el tercero que es 21 si
te diste cuenta esconder dos números y
escribir el tercero es igual a ir
sumando de tres en tres
por ejemplo 93 es igual a 12 12 más 3 es
igual a 15 15 más 3 es igual a 18 y 18
más 3 es igual a 21 perfecto como buenos
detectives descubrimos que el número que
seguía es 21 y que nuestra sucesión
cambia al sumar de tres en tres si
quisiéramos seguir agregando números a
la sucesión sólo tendríamos que sumarle
tres al número anterior o sea 21 más 3
igual a 24 y así sucesivamente
qué tal nada difícil verdad pero como sé
que tú eres un gran detective vamos a
descubrir más números ahora tenemos la
siguiente en sucesión 80
85 90 una rayita 100 105 y luego otra
rayita aunque veas números más grandes
no te preocupes la forma de resolverla
es la misma que aplicamos hace un
momento modo detective en 321
encontremos los números que faltan el
primer número que tenemos es 80 si
contamos de uno en uno aquí seguiría 81
82 83 84
y vemos el 85 recuerda que estos números
están escondidos por eso es que solo
vemos el 85 contemos son 1 2 3 4 y el
quinto es el que está en la sucesión
cierto tenemos que ir sumando de 5 en 5
del 85 al 90 lo hacemos de la misma
forma 86 87 88 89 y llegamos al 90
volvemos a tener cuatro números
escondidos y el quinto ya está escrito
guau ya llegamos al 90 como puedes ver
después de este número hay una rayita y
luego un 100 qué significa esto nosotros
hemos ido sumando de 5 en 5 de acuerdo
sin embargo nuestra sucesión de un
brinco enorme del 90 al 100 entonces
tenemos que encontrar el número que va
en lugar de esa rayita como lo hacemos
sumando 5 al número anterior al 90 le
sumamos 590 más 5 es igual al 95 vamos
bien 80 85 90 95 100 105 te doy un
consejo entre detectives si te llegas a
encontrar con estos brincos en otras
sucesiones
identificar con tres puntitos un cuadro
o con espacios vacíos entre los números
ya casi terminamos del 95 para el 100 se
sumaron 5 95 5 es igual a 100 vamos muy
bien del 100 al 105 lo mismo 100 más 5
105 amigo detective para que por fin
hayamos completado nuestra misión
únicamente nos falta descubrir qué
número sigue después del 105 como lo
hemos hecho sumaremos 5 105 5 110 lo
logramos 80 85 90 95 100 105 y 110 ves
nuestra sucesión va sumando de cinco en
cinco y así podrás llegar hasta el
infinito pero esa misión te la dejo a ti